and the veteran right-hander 35-year-old
29th start today fourth of the season
against the san francisco giants loves
pitching at home here 16 home starts
opponents hitting 208
overall
era a 4.13 we are ready to go
on the ground right side ranging is
hosmer darvish covers and makes a nice
play throws a little bit in front of him
but he reaches out to make the grab tags
the bag and retires la stella
and a swing of the miss you darvish
picks up his first k of the day
skies one to center
grisham battling the sun as he moves to
right center makes the catch
and now walks are not something you
expect to see from logan webb neither
are strikeouts he gets a ton of ground
balls about as much
or as many as anybody in baseball works
quickly throws strikes
and 3-1 pitches grounded right side
that's a fair ball gonna go down the
line belt was playing off the line
that's going to be an extra basis for
adam fraser into second base wade fires
in and frazier's standing up with the
lead off double it's here for the padres
to get to webb in the first and second
third with one down
ball four and hosmer defers to load them
up
bases loaded one out and jerks and
profar coming up here's the o2 and
profile takes down and in did it hit him
it did he will go to first base and a
run will come home
grisham lines one to left bryant coming
in we'll make the catch tagging at third
as fernando here comes the throw he will
be
safe
gets in and puts padres on top two to
nothing as sac flying to left and two on
and two out now haas at second profile
at first for hassan kim the seventh man
to bat this inning
on the ground and into right field
cosmo being waved around throw will go
to second and the padres put a three
spot on the board in the first inning
hassan kim with a good a b
ferratini now be the eighth man to bat
in the inning he's got runners on the
corners two outs
here's the pitch and caratini floats it
over crawford into left center for a
base hand profile will score and now a
four nothing lead for the pods in the
first inning
down the right field line toward the
corner that is gonna one hop up against
the wall
pro far with wade digging for second
throw is much too late that's a lead-off
double that's a great at bat
and it leaves it to yaz to try and get
wade home as they try not to waste this
lead off double
to deep right field this one is gone
mike yastrevsky
with one swing of the bat has put the
giants back in this game that's big well
and it's big for logan webb too because
it's letting them know that hey our guys
can swing it
man a swing and a miss darvish strikes
him out fourth strikeout for you darvish
2-2 pitch
and uh
fly ball to shallow left center look out
and coming from center is grisham
now here is bryant
did that one hit him and he says it did
the play-doh chris gucciane appeared to
ask him the padres are checking with
their video room it does look like it it
hit brian on the the left hand now did
it hit the hand or did it hit the the
knob of the bat
ball so bringing them back
darvish deals and a high chopper up the
middle fernando long way to go to his
left but he's got it underhand flip
[Applause]
now there's a
slider struck him out swinging a ball
grabbed in the dirt by
not going anywhere grisham on the ground
we'll see if the giants can turn two
that's one and they got the double play
curveball that time and
recognizable out of the hand even the
count of one and one the ethos that was
very slow yeah 69.
the shift is in play and it is right to
jake cronenworth and the perfect spot
swinging a miss and darvish is able to
strike out brandon crawford that is five
strikeouts now for you darvish
swinging a miss and he strikes sound
longoria back-to-back case for darvish
there's the o2 from dartmouth china
ground ball slowly to the right side
tatis charges has it flips to kim one on
to first in time and a double play
base head
the stella who is not running with the
pitch will stop at second
two on nobody out
and the biggest at bat of the game for
the giants here chris bryant has a
chance to really build the pressure on
the padres
swinging a miss
and he strikes out bryant picks up his
seventh strikeout slater on the season
hitting 229 with 10 homers 12 doubles
very fast keep that in mind
down to the field line into the corner
deep
goodbye
a three-run homer can you believe that
for austin slater over that five-foot
high wall in the left-field corner he
has turned this game completely around
five to four giants
and he
demolished it the pinch hit home run
from austin slater it's bottom of the
six inning two outs the base is empty
there's some up there lefty to lefty
against quintana
now the 3-2 grisham hits it in the air
deep to right field way back gonna go
home run trent grisham this game is tied
in the sixth inning so much for that
lead for the giants five five at petco
park double whammy for the giants as
hassan kim stands in
as kim hits a fly ball to deep center
field that goes slater at the wall they
go back to back grisham first and now ha
some kim back-to-back home runs and the
friars lead it six to five
[Applause]
gets himself into scoring position and
now tommy listella will come up wilmer
trying to get as good of a lead as
possible stella out toward left center
field grisham chasing he's not gonna get
it it lands and that'll be an easy send
wilmer flores in to score that ties the
game le stella into second with a double
[Applause]
line to center field that's a base hit
for hosmer that's going to roll all the
way back to the track and the wall
hosmer to second base with a two-out
double
jerkshin
two career walk-off hits last one came
last year against the rockies
the o2
pro far to center field duggar is there
to make the catch
that leaves it up to duggar a
left-handed hitter
duggar hits it on the ground at first
hosmer's got it he's got a hurry he gets
there
first and second down nobody out and
hassan kim coming up for the padres
kim bunting this time drops it down
looking everywhere the throw is just in
time and the winning run 90 feet away in
pro far here is victor caratini
on the ground up the middle diving at
second lustela the throw is late the
padre is walking off and from third
comes profar